had his share of rough and disappointing
postseason performances
he has been playing his heart out in
this series
so much responsibility without kawhi
leonard
and clippers need him to be aggressive
but efficient as you guys keep talking
about
they've scored ten straight the lead
back up to nine
oh chris paul goes down hard on his back
as beverly swiftly for the foul beverly
laughing and
mocking paul
proud letting beverly know what they
think of it
he could care less meanwhile the key
thing now for phoenix is that
chris paul get hurt he couldn't brace
himself on the fall
they're going to review it
see if it meets the criteria that's not
a flagrant foul that's a foul it's not a
flavor
beverly trying to fight over the screen
and paul wisely drawing the contact but
no that was no deliberate trip or
anything there we did brace the fall a
little bit with that left hand
[Applause]
both of those guys are so good at
the theatrics right and he's saying that
you know chris paul
flopped or whatever
no but it's a foul but one thing that
makes patrick beverly a great defender
against chris paul devin booker is
if you're paul a booker you know he's
capable of doing something dirty
you know he's capable of coming on not
that he's a dirty player but he's going
to take every bit of edge that he can
get
so he may hit you he may run through you
whatever it is
that